come to this video playing alias what
should I play okay that's that's
transposed to the Queens gambit okay if
you play c4
it doesn't the London instead yeah this
is one of the good lines against the
London Queens to do a queen bee sixes
uncommon
I have quick could be five before
available now then going for that oops
even strengthening my pawns by pawns
okay
threatening before now he needs to play
rook c1 yeah really the only the only
way and now Knight b6 to a4 has the idea
going for counter play in the center not
e4
yeah the night only for a very annoying
piece
it's basically tying a rope to the
defense sometimes you can even sacrifice
him won't be - okay let's get the King
involved yeah
can I sacrifice their own be too
I don't have enough pieces in play it's
it's close yeah I'm very tempted to take
on Batum it's probably not objectively
enough okay come on let's do that I have
a real winning streak going here let's
let's try my luck yeah this is it is
very passive lots of pins and and pieced
piece being tied together him okay so
look a two or before I could also play
c5 yeah why not see far if he cannot
take here he can but it opens up my
bishop bit bishop and oh this is
embarrassing
I didn't didn't see that at all oops
this important pawn
no okay replace like that maybe this
isn't so bad why would you play kinky
for just politics
get your King King into completely into
danger strange subsea fibers are almost
made a few retreats
five king check you know it then this
one okay I need to take anyway it takes
on d5 with rooks now and SB one hanging
yeah I can at least take be one but
maybe I have something else this is
really this is Bishop c5 is almost made
so crossfire the King isn't a crossfire
here okay let's let's get the piece back
first things first
okay maybe pinpin the bishop Wow this is
complicated
look c4 is an enormous threat now
I don't see what you should play now
Brooksie force is very very very strong
winds the whole wall pieces basically I
don't see what you should do
yeah probably a very lucky game make
with a blunder be fire you could have
just taken on default with the pawn
instead of instead of taking with a king
taking with the king really was was a
very rare decision I didn't see after
the pawn recaptured there's nothing yeah
I think this is lost here I'll just win
material don't see how he should defend
here it's completely tied together
yeah still still working or is there
some better move take special check I
can take takes King takes bishop a to
check you can take a to look at to where
this is not so convincing it's not
something else let's let's check if I
take okay I have Bishop a to wills is
clear okay let's do that he needs to
give the exchange and it's still somehow
a very pinned position okay Bishop f6
something else it's probably threatening
to play King d3 so that it didn't can
move check him that says this should be
better give the trick and what's no but
I really found the defensive I thought
it was it was just winning check should
be life I'm such an idiot
Bishop e5 what the heck what an idiotic
game what that check don't get anything
here well maybe this is even good it's
completely unnecessary
but maybe it's even good he's playing
for the edge gone
yeah I see you've got a check here time
warning nonsensical game heartbreaking
really what the heck
okay check let's check now I could have
worn this no I could I can just take the
rook oh this is it's getting better and
better
after this I'm just a hookup great
check sorry
okay I took him and then if he played
this and this I know I said okay I'm
winning property too and why am I not
winning the computer has a minus five
look 1 2 a 2 as a win hmm it's not very
intuitive the smooth
and I also don't understand why this
winning
okay I'm threatening to take on D 2 and
C 4 and Bishop a 2 here maybe this is so
so so good but you cannot defend it also
computer wants to go here check yeah
just winning the piece
okay so I applied this and this is in
fact still the game continues yeah then
I just just blundered here but it's just
minus 0.5 so check yeah mighty I'm
already already in trouble
the look on a2 is saying it should be 5
What nonsense
look after I need to go but and I can't
stop India of course I need to move to
me I need to have 2 and then change them
check this way I'm just I'm just lost it
promotes what the crap game I could have
just taken B 5 here unbelievable just I
just didn't see it
ok thanks for watching